muss die polizei jetzt berlin weitaus
rücken noch während der räumung der
besetzten liebig straße 34 haben sich
zahlreiche splittergruppen gebildet die
wie hier nur wenige hundert meter
entfernt am frankfurter tor und der
frankfurter allee die einsatzkräfte
provozieren die polizei twittert von
zahlreichen angriffen auf beamte in der
näheren umgebung
es wird erwartet dass sich der protest
und weitere angriffe dezentral aus
weilburg mögliche ziele der linken
gruppen maklerbüros und büros von
gerichtsvollzieherin über die stadt
verteilt aber ich glaube wir müssen auch
sehen dass der einsatz heute natürlich
nicht beendet sein wird ja die kommenden
nächte kommenden wochen wären sicherlich
noch ein bisschen heiß weil die linke
szene zu gewalttaten auch gehört
vermutlich sollen so polizeikräfte
auseinandergezogen werden in sozialen
medien heißt es jede räumung hat ihren
preis und lasst uns die räumung zum
desaster machen wie zum beispiel auf dem
twitter kanal liebig 34 bleibt die
polizei die mit rund 1500 beamten im
einsatz ist und berlin stellen sich
demnach auf eine lange nacht ein
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren